- I'm doing two Your One Word book events
including one today in LA.
What's up Believe Nation!
So I got asked a lot from people
if I was doing a book tour
doing any events about the book
how they can meet me
get some signed copies.
And I thought
I don't know if I want to do it.
My publisher said not to do it
and so,
what I thought was,
listen, I'm traveling to LA.
I'm actually here
not right now,
but when you guys are watching this video,
I'm here in LA.
And I thought, let's do one in LA,
let's do one in Toronto,
and then we'll see how it goes.
So the LA one, I have a
meeting in Beverly Hills
that ends at three o'clock,
no
that starts at three o'clock Pacific
and so I thought,
hey let's do a five
o'clock Pacific meet up
in Beverly Hills for those of you
who want to get your book signed
want to talk about the book,
want to do a selfie, want
to meet, want to chat.
I'd love to meet you and hang out.
So that one is happening today.
You don't have a lot of time.
5pm Pacific today.
The address is
Peet's Coffee
258 South Beverly Drive
Beverly Hills, California 90212.
Hopefully you are in LA or in the LA area.
I will see you there
at five o'clock, today.
The second one is I'm watching a series of
Your One Word workshops in Toronto.
So if you're in the Toronto area,
we're doing our first one on April 3rd.
I'm going to be there.
I'm actually having my instructor
run it for me.
So Lily is one of my dance instructors
at Toronto Dance Salsa
whose embraced her one word.
And she's going to be
teaching a two hour workshop
on April 8th from one to three pm Eastern
going through the core
concepts in the book.
It's 40 dollars to join.
If you do, you get a free copy of the book
which is $35 so basically it balances out
and I'm also going to sign it.
And I'm going to be there
and answer questions and meet people.
So if you're in the Toronto area,
or you want to come to
Toronto to meet and talk,
April 8th
from one to 3pm Eastern.
You can sign up at TorontaDanceSalsa.ca
and hopefully I'll see you there.
So see how these first two events go.
We'll see how the turn out is
how the reaction is, how much fun it is,
chat with you guys, and
potentially expand the tour
beyond that, if
we feel like it's a good fit,
so let me know what you think.
Hopefully I'll see you at
one of those tour events.
And now I want to get
to some of the questions
from last week's video.
First up is Eric.
This was great insight to writing a book.
Glad you enjoyed it.
Last week I did a video of
the 10 lessons that I learned.
Things that I did right,
things that I did wrong.
Things I want to remind myself of
the next time I go
through this process again
if I do it again.
And yeah, the whole book
series has been a fun journey
of documenting and sharing with you guys
and anybody who's
trying to write a book
or wants to write a book.
Hopefully the headaches
that I went through
and the winds that I went through
documenting on that series
are beneficial to you.
That's why I made it.
And it was a fun series to put together.
Alykia, the cover isn't bad.
I like the second line
with the arrow pointing
to the highlighted word.
Yes, so I mentioned last week
that one of the things that I regretted
was not having more time
to do the cover.
I'm not a fan of this cover.
Actually in the first design
the arrow wasn't there
it was just Your One Word
and we added this is the
only change that I've made.
That I was allowed to make
basically in the timeframe
that we had.
So the arrow is
different words.
You can see it there.
The arrow is different words.
And so, I'm glad you like that.
That was our
our only change and
it's okay.
It's okay, it's a good cover.
It's not terrible.
I'm just
I'm not a fan of it.
I would've done something different.
But it's a good lesson learned.
It was still worth publishing the book.
The book itself is amazing.
And
I've come to live with the cover.
Next up,
Ops Endless,
does it have to be three
words for the credo
or can it be three statements?
The idea with the credo is
that it represents three ideas.
You have your one word
whether it's believe, whether it's family,
whether it's extraordinary,
whether it's belong,
whatever it is, you have your one word.
And then the credo helps you
add more definition to it for yourself
and also for other people looking at it
whether they're your customers
or suppliers or employees,
partners, your investors.
So they have a little better
understanding of what it means.
And so, the credo represents
three different concepts.
It could be three different words.
It could be
three different statements.
Although I wanted
I wanted you to make sure
they're easy to remember.
They're not these long sentences.
Because what happens,
it's always a tendency to
make it longer and longer
and longer and longer
and then you don't remember it.
I want these three things to be memorable.
So that if somebody asks
you what your credo is
you don't have to
open your notebook and find it.
You know it.
And so
that's the danger.
That's the risk.
If you make them long statements,
then you're not going to remember them.
If you don't remember them
then what's the point?
The whole point is that
it's easy to remember
so that you can start to live by it
and other people can know you by it
and they can know how to help you
know how to interact with you
know if they want to buy from you or not.
That's a hesitation doesn't have to be
three different words,
but I would really
strongly recommend that you
shrink it down.
Next up, nonstop.
Hi Evan, I love your videos.
Can you make a video about,
"how to spend your money best,
"in your company?"
So at the start, I'm not a
big fan of spending any money.
I like to build stuff up
using my energy, my heart,
my time,
my effort
and not spending money
until I'm making money.
And so,
it's thinking whether I spend my time to
get some dollars coming in.
I had this big vision for
where I want to take something.
You have this big vision for
where you want to take something
and you're starting here at the bottom.
And it's okay.
A lot of people want to
take these giant steps,
but if you try to take a giant step,
you're going to make a lot of mistakes.
And so if you take out
a mortgage on your house
to take this big giant
step and it doesn't work,
you might be in debt for
the rest of your life now
because of this extra
loan that you took out.
I don't want that for you.
I want you to prove to yourself
that it's worth spending your time,
worth spending more dollars
in it.
And so, at the beginning,
I'm spending zero dollars.
Where should you spend your money?
No where.
Keep it in your bank account.
Keep it in your investments.
Until you get to the part
where you're making money.
Once you start making money,
you're investing a lot of
it back into your business
and from there, I'm looking
at what is going to give me
the highest return on my dollars?
Just like you want to be thinking
what's giving me the
highest return on my time?
Any resource you have,
this is what being an
entrepreneur is all about.
Any resource you have
is going to be limited.
You have limited funds,
you have limited team.
Maybe zero right now.
You have limited time.
Everything is limited.
It's what do you do with
that limited resource?
What do you do with your money?
What do you do with your time?
What do you do with the
connections that you have?
The friends, the family,
maybe people in your team,
volunteers, whatever it is,
how do you best use
all of those resources?
What's going to generate
the biggest result
for the least amount of input.
And so, when you pour dollars on something
you want it to be gasoline, right?
So it's like, hey I've started
this marketing campaign
it's working.
Now if I put some money into it,
it's going to work even more.
Right?
And you test it, and you
test it, and you test it,
and you see what's working,
you find something,
and I like to go all in on that
dominate it, crush it, explode it,
that's why I want folks to manage it
because it's working.
First, I'm making sure
that I'm making some kind of money on it
and then two, I'm looking at okay
how do I
find the thing that if
I put a dollar in it
I'm getting five out.
So, it could be a lot
of different activities.
It speaks to where your strengths are,
what your market is.
There's no one answer that
put all your money into Instagram ads.
That may be a great strategy
or it may not if you don't
know what you're doing.
So, that's my advice.
Good luck.
Next up, The Howling Chihuahua.
I love that name.
Your One Word is a badass book
because it inspired me to be fearless
in my entrepreneur journey.
Thanks EC and his people.
I love that.
That's why I wrote the book.
I had tremendous success
using these strategies.
And I was having success
with the people around me
adopting those strategies.
And I wanted to share it with you guys.
I wanted to share with entrepreneurs.
I struggled so much
in getting my first
business off the ground.
And the reason I do all of this
is I wanted to make your
journey a little bit easier.
I'm kind of thinking back to myself
trying to help the 19 year old Evan
who's starting his first
business and sucking and failing
and
down and feeling worthless
because nothing was working out.
And everything that I do is
kind of thinking back to that
entrepreneur.
Trying to help him
not quit because I did quit.
And I came back, thankfully.
But I wanted to make the
road a little more easier
for
other entrepreneurs who
are going through it.
And all the content that I make,
that's the purpose.
And when I discovered the
strategies that became the book,
I need to share this, I
need to get this out there,
people need to see this stuff.
They need to apply it.
And so it's awesome, what did you say?
You're fearless
in your entrepreneur journey.
I love it.
I love seeing the success
stories coming in.
Thank you for leaving that comment.
It really really means a lot to me
knowing that you guys
are picking up copies
and seeing the benefit of it.
There's another comment
from The Howling Chihuahua.
I love your thumb ring, hashtag beautiful.
I don't actually have a thumb ring.
I just move my ring around.
When I'm thinking,
I
I play with my ring.
I like the motion.
So, usually it sits on
one of my two
what are these fingers?
Ring fingers I guess, right?
Where the ring is?
But often when I'm thinking or speaking
I'll pop it on the thumb.
It's not
it obviously does not fit on the thumb,
right?
It doesn't fit there.
But,
that's me.
It's fun.
And then he also wrote,
if you ever come to the Fresno area,
I hope you give me five
minutes of your time
to get an autograph on your badass book
after I attend your seminar.
All entrepreneurs need to
get this Your One Word book
to step up their entrepreneur game.
Thank you for being awesome.
Well, I'm not coming to Fresno,
but I'm coming to LA.
I don't know how big of
a drive that is for you,
but
get working on it.
Hopefully I'll see you soon.
Next up, Sharif,
I've done decades of graphic
design or related work.
I don't think you're looking
at your cover objectively Evan.
You should be happy as it
is an excellent modern,
yet simple, informative yet clear,
original yet professional,
different yet minimalist.
It's easily an above-average book cover.
Any simpler and it would
look less greeting,
any more designed and it
would have looked too busy.
Listen, a lot of people
like the book cover.
My agent loves the book cover,
my publisher loves the book cover,
I'm sure the people in the art department
love the book cover.
I come at it from two perspectives.
One,
when you say it's easily an
above average book cover,
that doesn't get me excited.
I don't want to be an
above average anything.
Like the things that I'm spending
a year of my time creating
I don't want it to just be above average.
Like that
that upsets me
deeply.
That the work that I'm
spending so much time on
because the content in the book is not
just above average.
It's way better than above average.
And so, I'm upset that
the cover that reflects it
is just above average.
And the second part is
a lot of this is what
comes from the heart.
When you look at something,
art is subjective.
So, I look at that, and
I'm just not moved by it.
I want to be moved by it.
You may be moved by it, you may like it.
Lot of people like it,
but,
ideally, I want to look
at something and say,
"Man!
"Look at that cover!"
And every time I look at it, I remember
Believe or I remember the impact
or I'm just,
I'm wowed by it
and this just doesn't do it.
Like these pictures behind
me are here for a reason.
The selection, the angle of faces,
the everything, the size
it's all designed
and picked
with
with importance!
With relevance.
There's a reason why they're all here.
There's a reason why there's five.
And there's a reason why
they're looking certain ways.
There's a reason for all of it
and I got to do that,
and I'm happy.
I love walking in here everyday.
Like
you know
I just don't love it, that's all.
I love that you guys love it.
I just don't love it.
It's okay.
I'm not complaining.
Next time, it's a good lesson for me
that I got to do better.
I got to plan it out more.
I got to spend just as
much time on the outside
as I did on the inside.
Last up, Aiden Clayton.
Biggest influencers of 2016,
Eric Thomas, Tai Lopez,
Gary Vee, Tony Robbins,
and Evan Carmichael.
Keep going my guy.
Wow, thank you for the love Aiden.
It's an honor to be
included in that group.
I'm glad I'm having an impact on your life
and hopefully using the
content to do great things
in your business.
And spreading the message to
others to help influence them
as well.
So thank you guys for the love.
I'm looking forward to meeting you.
Hopefully today in LA.
If not, April 8th in Toronto.
And if not, leave your
questions down below
and I will answer them
in next week's episode.
Thank you guys for joining me.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.